leave the keys
you still do that thing leave the keys
we can offer our biggest discounts on 30
recycled and Ultra Premium laser okay
okay phone
yeah sure go ahead
so I'm talking about a few of the other
things we can offer namely we know the
tax season is coming up so by April 1st
we can have you fully stocked the
discount prices on ink cartridges three
and also any forms that you're going to
need seven you can custom make them
you just said hi hi
my niece and she's six months old
but I appreciate what you guys are
saying but it makes more fiscal sense to
go with one of the big guys sure it's
true we can't compete with their prices
but let me ask you something how
important to you is customer service
please keep holding your call is very
important to us
um it's one of the big guys been on hold
this whole time and this has done a
Mifflin
hey Kelly it's Jim
here's my card
it's got my cell number my pager number
my home number and my other pager number
I never take vacations I never get sick
and I don't celebrate any major holidays
all right I get it we gotta do all right
hey Kelly screw you
excuse me that is no way to address your
Superior oh yeah screw you
tick oh
what was that all about you forgot her
birthday
it was yesterday
you do it
okay I insist
basically after Phil's blackmailed
Angela Michael asked them both to step
down from the party planning committee
because there was too much drama what he
said was easy there was a problem with
having one head of the party planning
committee she becomes too powerful so he
pointed two heads
party plan this is literally the
stupidest City humiliating
that's
on my side
so this is fun
are you kidding I'm not done yet
wait
this fits in the palm of my hand
you haven't blown them up enough
why have you chosen Brown and gray
balloons they match the carpet what is
that
it is your birthday period even a fact
not even an exclamation point this is
more professional it's not like she
discovered a cure for cancer I can't
believe I've had the smokes
are you trying to hurt my feelings
because if so you are succeeding
fortunately my feelings regenerated
twice the speed of a normal Lance good
then have you collected the money from
everyone I am working on it how much do
you have
six dollars
that's how much you and I contributed
damn it Jim
I said I was working on
you have to write my suggestions down
too I'm not writing horse hunt
I don't even know what that means it's
in the name
okay so far
our Ideal Party consists of beer fights
of the death cupcakes blood pudding
blood touch football mating charades and
yes horse hunting you're right forget
horse hunting it's stupid is there a
birthday that you remember that you
loved here's one
it was dark warm wet
a sudden burst of light an intense
pressure like I'd never felt before
father dressed in white pulls me forward
mother bites the cord okay stop
forever it's not that story that's
disgusting and it doesn't count so give
me another one celebrate birthdays idiot
it started as a depression-era
practicality and then moved on to an
awesome tradition that I look forward to
every year
what about you actually when I was seven
my dad took me to the Natural History
Museum in New York and we looked at
fossils all day and at the end of the
day he got me a little plastic
Triceratops it was awesome
cool hey you know what's even cooler
than Triceratops
every other dinosaur that ever existed
fencing that one coming
Jim you know it would be really
dastardly If We snuck out of here and
got to The Client First
[Laughter]
he's running
damn it
what what is this supposed to be it's
monkey
Jim get real this is not a monkey
it's got a hula skirt and a blue nose
hold on hold on is this him what is that
him
do something get out what am I gonna do
I don't go slash his tires go dead his
hood
that's it oh that's great that's like a
five second delay white go
does this thing have turbo nitrous hit
the nas Nas
you mean like in Fast and Furious yeah
oh yeah I definitely have not hit the
nas are you sure yes brace yourself
three two go one here we go
ready go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go
foreign
yeah you're an exec a Pennsylvania solar
Tech that's he's fake I told you you're
an exec at Stark Industries inspiration
you inherited from your father here's
the story they need Meredith somewhere
else ASAP okay so you're taking over you
just gotta get her out of there as soon
as you can all right I can do that then
what then make him pitch to you you
gotta see what he's got exactly you
can't remember do this you're not gay
stop it it's gonna be great unless if
anything else happens just roll with it
thank you
Meredith oh I uh well this is Manuel my
cleaning man he doesn't speak any
English
uh Manuel cleano El window
of course we got
so this hot chocolate thing none of your
business well you know you can't
actually poison them right it isn't
poison it's a laxative people take
laxatives all the time this is just a
lot more of a laxative let me handle it
I really think we should join forces on
this one really what do we think what
would drive him crazy
here we go
Pepto-Bismol in his hot chocolate got to
stop with the hot chocolate stuff
I was thinking maybe we could Jam his
drawers so they only come out two inches
and then that way you can see everything
in them but you can't get it does Edgar
Allan Poe know about that one so
Sinister
that wouldn't annoy a person at all were
you where do you come up with this stuff
okay all right well this isn't my best
but call froggy101. say that we're the
tour manager for Justin Bieber and we're
giving away free tickets we give them a
number to call for the tickets and it's
his number who is Justice beaver
it's a crime fighting Beaver oh thanks
we'll do absolutely now when you get
down there Joe's a little bit uh
forgetful so she may have locked the
gate but what you're going to do is go
ahead hop it and just head back to the
pool
it is weird look at you perceptive now I
know why Joe's kept her eye on you
and you make sure to get down there
check out the Harry Potter World
whatever you want to do in your spare
time is up to you Harry Potter world is
supposed to be fantastic apparently as
soon as corporate found out I wanted to
come in off the road Joe offered me a
cushy new job in Tallahassee and here's
the best part I'm a huge alligator nerd
I can name you every genus every
subspecies
also I'm a huge boob nerd check it out
and bring those swimming trunks bye now
bye I cannot believe this you're sending
Packer to Florida why using my desk okay
so you're tricking him into flying to
Florida this wasn't my first choice Jim
had so many better ideas you have to
tell him you've sell them what you did
no no no no no no no no no no that that
is not in the plan that is actually anti
what we're doing he is my oldest friend
I am going to tell him wait why don't we
come up with a plan that we're all happy
about that